yeah let's see what hugo has to say
it's crazy how they just put a tv in the
middle of the villa for us to look at i
know it's great really convenient shut
the [ __ ] up hey [ __ ] you
okay
when lib pulls you for chats after jakey
wanted to get to know millie
but the show didn't air it to protect
gibberdy and not
that didn't happen dude
that didn't it's also like nobody gives
a [ __ ] anymore dude the show's over doc
what are you doing
yeah this is sad
yeah
no i do flirt i do flirt
nobody [ __ ] cares about i flirt
i do flirt no lib wanted to [ __ ] me too
she was mildly about one point
first of all man
the producers tell her to pull you okay
yeah like let's not get it confused also
you were voted off like five weeks ago
yeah
and bro it's not like you pulled her
you know what i mean it would be it'd be
a little bit more understandable if he's
like well you know i pulled lib yeah and
i you know i got it but it's like
no you didn't you didn't affect anything
you also yeah you didn't make the move
here yeah
you're just like you're zabozo
so what he should have did was he should
have said this on the show after that
happened that
would have been good yeah
i hate this like formula now you go on a
reality show and then right after all of
your tick tocks get half a million likes
yeah at least
oh my god that's the guy that was on the
show that i just watched
like like follow watch
well you know 400 000 of these people
are
you know potential 10 year olds he may
teach
because
he ain't going to be an influencer hugo
tell us my class tell us about that time
that
he's trying to teach him like geography
or some [ __ ]
do i tell us more about liberty
oh well
i'll have you know she pulled me for
chats
when jakey wanted to get to know me he's
cool he's like he's like he's like 60.
yeah he's still talking about it yeah
hey roasting the gang i got to see this
oh no damn he's just straight burning
bridges
okay
lily casa what what in the
what is this
wait did
okay what did he say about himself
what the [ __ ] posit
weaknesses love island girls after sun
strength's friendship being himself now
i think your weakness is
oh
yeah that's that sucks i think your
biggest weakness is you my friend
all right that was mean that was me i'm
sorry but do you realize that he put him
in his his own strengths yeah was
friendship and being himself
yeah
yeah i don't
you know whatever i mean those are good
qualities to have in like first grade
yeah
you're on like the most savage
reality show ever okay you have to be a
dog no that's what i'm saying that's all
i'm comparing yup
all right the summer of love hasn't gone
to plan
why not
so let's manifest the winter of love
all due at this around christmas when
i've met the girl of my dreams we are on
a date a lot of pressure man we're both
dressed
yeah a lot of pressure drinking hot
chocolate's happy and healthy
england are 1-0 up in the
in the ashes down under
way too much pressure wow
we should remember to do at that if it
doesn't happen yeah yeah you know
inevitably
oh man i don't want to see this i don't
even
like literally close that let's watch it
don't watch it
[Music]
yo that little [ __ ] at the end where
he's like this is a joke by the way uh
what does that say
well this is a joke i did try as best as
oh this is this is a joke in the caption
yeah
if you have to twice explain that this
is a joke it's probably not the best not
a good bit yeah
look man this is inevitably gonna get to
him when you guys go raid his comments
and you're like go look at the [ __ ]
don't do it yeah don't do it look i i'm
not even trying to backtrack like i
don't hate the guy
i just think he's not meant for reality
tv yeah
that's all man
hugo i mean like just like
go be a teacher man
that's okay that's
all right have i ever told you kids
about the time that liberty
pulled me for a chat what the [ __ ] are
you talking about but the show never
showed it
those damn editors
they know she wanted me jakey wanted to
get to know millie
hugo
you need to take what's in the cup oh
you need to take she's
his head back i'll throw them down his
neck and then we'll pump it full of
water she would never give me the egg
you have to take your tranquilizer you
go
oh jesus that's what castlemore is gonna
be in 10 years when they take all the
like burnt out love island castmates and
they just it's like it becomes like a
geriatric home
all just in there
feeding them cheap liquor and
keeping them on life support yeah you
guys want to party tonight yeah who
wants a party
i do i do i love parties i sound so
shitty they're only like 40.
the show ages on my 50 years do you
remember when they all used to smoke
yeah that was the best
yeah one they're ripping cigs all of
them love that jack and darts dude john
what john yeah john
he's uh he was like the winner from
season one
spoiler alert so good man yeah but i
think
when did i start third third
john from season one
is uh
he made season one
he was smashing in broad day
and at night in front of everyone [ __ ]
confidence man really literally like
everyone's like
yeah literally everyone in the room is
like
are you serious oh john not again
oh just turn around in it cover your
ears
yeah yeah he was like
there was i there's one episode where
he's like
he just tells everyone hey i'm sorry i'm
really [ __ ] horny and just does it
it's just like he's like i i'm sorry
everyone i just i i can't wait anymore
it's unreal like how how much of the
show has changed yeah like did they even
do the declarations of love no like no
it's weird that they
who the [ __ ] is making a coffee right
now
classic sounds like a keurig doesn't it
um
yeah they use yeah they used to sit out
by the pool
they just [ __ ] rip schmegs and just
smash in public yeah
and just put out there cigarettes and oh
yeah
all right who wants to suck me off fair
play
all right then
all right then
and now it's
they're basically getting married at the
end that [ __ ] was weird that was creepy
man it's weird they did that on love
island us
did they yeah like with in carrington
season with johnny and then they started
like dress up in the tux and a dress
it's weird they just robbed them of any
bit of like
norm like normality in their
relationship outside yeah it's like did
you think there was a shot you two are
gonna get married we're gonna [ __ ] that
up i'm gonna [ __ ] that up by moving this
way too quickly yeah hey write vows i
know you guys have known each other for
four weeks but write vows to each other
right now
like
i felt for the people like
i felt like kaz was so clearly
uncomfortable because her speech was so
dialed back yeah it had like some weird
metaphor for riding a horse because i'm
sure she was like i don't want to say
all this stuff like tell me you love him
yeah you want to try it come on drop the
l bomb
listen
i can't tell you the numbers
yeah but it's close
no but do you do you do you you know do
you do you
do you and i mean the votes are still
rolling in we're not closing these polls
for another
hour or two and you realize when this
comes out it's like it's like a full
hour
yep come on so but you do whatever you
want move your own pace we get it we get
it we don't want to push things or rush
things but liam just asked me to be his
girlfriend so
and you and tyler are just exclusive
yeah
so
so i mean hmm
charts show you know the studies show
that the the uk public they love a
girlfriend a boyfriend relationship not
so much exclusive doesn't have the same
weight yeah
so i mean you can move at your own pace
whatever yeah do what you want just you
know back yourself back yourself you
guys love saying that back yourself but
just know that
this is fifty thousand dollars on the
line
pounds actually it's about a hundred
thousand u.s
so so that's a lot of money i mean
that's life-changing money
but do whatever you want you know i'm
just saying you know not can't say the
exact numbers but it's close
it's close
just saying that you know
you don't want to [ __ ] this up
yeah you know what they'd love even more
actually
a proposal oh
hauntai
what do you think what do you think what
are you thinking
i mean
ellie and liam i can't say exactly i
mean they're i'll tell you something
they're in the lead all right they're
beating you but by just a little bit
selling cars yeah it's nothing that
something a little bit more you know
with more emotional weight can't change
let's just say that